this is a weak to the topography crit
and this one is going to be a little bit
different than last time I think I've
learned a few things to help you guys
get the most out of this learning
opportunity I've invited my friend and
fellow type instructor Luca Brooke I'm
who's in this group right now and shield
NFI herself in a little bit but she's a
fellow Arts Centre's classmate of mine
she's taught typography at a bunch of
different schools has worked
professionally for many decades now so
I'm really thrilled to have her Milka
how are you doing hi thank you good
morning for having me I'm excited okay
excellent so nOCA there was a little
tech confusion this morning so she's
gonna dig through the files that were
submitted I think every week we're
getting more submission so it's becoming
harder and harder for us to sort through
them and pick out what we want to talk
about something to give her a little
time to kind of get her bearings
straight and she has the bounce at 12:30
so we're gonna see how much we can do in
this hour and a half that we have
together before she has to bail now last
time people were telling me I didn't
give enough context of what's going on
so I'm gonna give me a little context so
people have enrolled in the typography
course with us in an effort to maximize
our learning opportunity together
especially everybody's isolated
self-quarantine will just work for home
thing that we're doing we've decided to
do a classroom kind of thing where we
can all learn together so this is what
it is it's seven weeks worth of work and
we're in week two everybody's given the
exact same amount of copy and the
instructions were included in the course
and then of course they uploaded it and
everybody is using some version of
Helvetica as I was digging through the
files apparently there are more verses
of Helvetica than I own and so some of
the files didn't open properly so that
was problematic for me unfortunately
okay so let's dig right into it I'm
gonna get going and today I've added an
additional camera here it's totally a
useless camera because you can see my
hands I don't know I have an extra
camera I'm gonna use it from time to
time I'm dangerous with technology guys
and we'll get going so back to my camera
here I'm gonna go ahead and share my
screen and get going if you guys have
questions oh my gosh this
looks different and by the way we have
about 25 students from the typography
class joining us here so ex liability
okay I think I've selected this oh no I
have to change my preferences guys give
me a second here I updated my OS wisely
two days ago so everything is crazy okay
I have to quit I'll be right back you
guys okay talk to the people or Marta
talk to them tell them what's up maybe
run that problem I have to quit and I'll
rejoin okay okay so since Chris has quit
well we'll just give you guys another
quick idea of what's going on so the
typography course is contains seven
exercises and this week we review
reviewing exercise 2 where we're able to
use two weights but one point sighs so
Chris and milk are going to review some
of the submissions and I saw last week's
episode we get into the nitty-gritty
about just basically learning how to see
so yoga is one of the she's actually
worked with Chris over at art center and
milk I don't know if you wanted to say
anything about what you if I may just
tell everyone
hi I'm really honored to be here thank
you for having me I did teach this class
hierarchy of typography for 15 years to
over 1,500 students and I can tell you
what a powerful program this is you are
learning so much through these series of
exercises and I know how difficult or
challenging some of them may be it's
rigorous it's a very rigorous program
but it's just engraving it in you and
you'll be shocked that when somebody
comes up to you and says hey can you
design this for me
you'd be like no problem I can whip it
out why because these exercises have
been ingrained in you and you just have
gone through so
layers of practices that you are able to
whip these things out in no problem and
I'm curious to know how this exercises
are planned because the way I would plan
it is every week we would add a
parameter so week one it was one size
one size one weight and up and probably
one of the major aspects that many of
the students had to deal with was with
space you had to learn how to organize
elements on the page layout to figure
out what works best in terms of
hierarchy now when we say hierarchy what
do we mean by hierarchy hierarchy means
what's the first read what's the second
read and what's the third read so what's
the first thing your eye goes to boom
it's probably the darkest and the
biggest am i right by the way I'm not
getting any feedback here so I don't
know everyone can hear me or not talking
foe okay good thank you for that
feedback I just want to make sure
give me some chuckle here and there to
sign up being here so the question is
what's the first three second read and
third read and if you think about it
usually the darkest element is what
stands at first but then week one our
challenge was that there's no there's no
dark or light everything is one size one
size that is challenging so the question
is then how else can I create a
hierarchy what if I have if everything
is the same what if we have more
less and least amount so think about
that large medium small and that's your
next friend in terms of hierarchy large
medium small and then of course from
there you go to dark medium light and
then as you as a class progresses then
you want to think about long medium
short or tall medium short and as the
class progresses all these factors
starts to work with one another and
interact with each other and that's when
it becomes really fascinating and even
more challenging you thought week 1 was
challenging uh-huh Rickman was a piece
of cake all right but your work is gonna
start to look really more cook and
really more dynamic and that's the
beauty of it so just be aware of these
different hierarchies write them out put
them in front of you and I'll repeat
again and if you guys want to take notes
so the first one of the first elements
of hierarchy to create hierarchy is by
mass so we're talking about large medium
small and then this week as we're
dealing with two weights which is large
and small then we're talking about dark
darkest we haven't gone to the other
element which is medium and then light
so bold regular light and then help me
out what was the third one that I talked
about somebody help me out here I could
show them a quick screenshot also of the
exercise and I think Chris might be back
on here but so on the left here you
could see the text that Chris had
created here and it's essentially a
title the name of the journal and then
some information but they're breaking it
down into elements based on the criteria
weekly criteria here on the right so the
play button is stuck here but the first
week is one weight one point size
second is two eights one point size and
so on and so forth and this really helps
you I narrow down all of the factors
that go into this so that you're
focusing mainly on the hierarchy and how
to see their information fantastic thank
you so much for sharing that as we may
continue with with hierarchy some of the
other elements of asking keep asking
yourself these questions whenever you're
doing any design any work and you don't
know ask yourself these questions and
think about it and you might want to
even brainstorm with with somebody who's
sitting next to you and ask them what
are your thoughts here's the thing none
of us have all the answers but it is
together that we have all the answers
does that make sense so when you're
working on these design factors and
you're asking yourself well what am I
supposed to do what else am I supposed
to do talk it out either talk it out
with yourself or with another person now
two o'clock in the morning you have
nobody to talk to right right you have
no one to talk to so what do you do two
o'clock in the morning I Chris your bag
let me know when you want to stop I'm
ready to go that Mister thought okay I'm
gonna finish my thought you print out
your work and you put it up on the wall
and you walk away from it and then you
come and look at it from a fresh
standpoint of view and you'll be
surprised how the solutions are going to
do just showed themselves up in front of
you Chris thank you for covering for me
I realize there's a lot of security
updates and patches that were a part of
the OS upgrade and so every application
now has to be authorized by you to
access other screens and I applaud Apple
for doing that especially in light of
some of the leaks that have been or
people hacking into zoom I realized Noga
you're a very different kind of
instructor than me and I'm really glad
to have you on the show you bring such a
warm caring gentle nurturing energy it's
very different than what I bring so I'm
looking forward to how our different
styles of teaching are going to mesh
together okay
that's without further ado I apologize
everybody we're back
I got everything working hasn't opened
up online files and it was a nightmare
anyways everybody let's jump into I'm
gonna share my screen with you guys and
so this week what I'm gonna do is a
little bit different I'm going to start
off by critiquing I think what is it 17
people so I picked one image from or one
layout submission and we'll go through
this not all of these are great so I'm
gonna have some problems and as I was
going through your files I realize lots
of different things that we're not
working the smartest way like when we
have assets we're not preparing them and
we're gonna start fighting against
ourselves in the design I'm gonna jump
in right now so first up I'm gonna zoom
into this and you're gonna see this is
Bhuvan bonne nuit I'm not sure how to
say his name or her name and if you if I
click on this you'll notice that it's in
the text box you see this text box here
which makes it really hard to work with
because it's a list and the list doesn't
need to be put in a text box a list
should be handled like this when I
select this there's no text box it's
much easier for me to manipulate rotate
and do that kind of stuff and this text
box is going to get in my way and I'm
gonna show to you right now every time I
go and try and select something near see
how I'm grabbing so much around it and
every one of these things is inside a
text box so use that for when you have a
paragraph for example I have something
right here so in in a case like this
this is in a text box and why you want
to do that because it's a paragraph and
you could you can alter the width and
the length of it but when it comes to
lists prepare them like this they're
much easier to move around you could
adjust the letting you can adjust
everything it's just super easy to work
with okay so we're talking about hygiene
their digital hygiene and this will
allow you to do what you're meant to do
which is the design Explorer and play
around okay and the other thing is that
we're not using layers correctly there's
the layer on top here watch if i zoom
out and I need to tell you this as you
dive deeper into this course you're
fighting yourself here so there's this
mask layer right so all my mass is on
one layer so if I lock that now I'm not
gonna accidentally select that thing I
noticed because I've created this for
you foreground mid-ground and background
layers for you people are only using one
lair so make sure you guys jump into the
layer palette and do that all right
that's really really important for you
to do right now okay next is anything
that's black or something that's grey in
the background it's gonna be put on a
separate layer so it's easy for me Oh No
my thing just crashed am I still there
we still see the screen they go that's
weird okay anyways I put the black layer
and so this way I'm gonna lock that so
all I have to do is now I'm just gonna
work on this and I have to constantly
select and deselect what we're getting
into before my machine crashes the
Internet's being tested right now with
everybody streaming content okay
I'm gonna encourage everybody here to
try to resist designing on an angle off
axis like this because it's actually
kind of difficult to do because when you
want to keep things aligned it's quite
difficult so make sure you understand
the principles first in in aligning
things when it's straight perpendicular
and horizontal vertical work with that
first once you get an understanding of
that and then start throwing things off
access okay now there's a couple things
going on here as I said last week if you
just made this hype a little bit smaller
it's gonna give you more room to design
so that there's more white space and if
I look at this type it's sixteen point
type okay if all I do is make this a
little bit smaller it's gonna help us
out a lot but refrain from doing that
this time around okay now we have major
grid lines here so if I'm gonna draw a
line this time let's say it's like right
around here okay so I hope everybody can
see that I'm gonna beef this line up and
I'm gonna make it a bright color so you
guys can see that and go to my
properties panel here and bump up the
point size a little bit okay so when
we're working with that this is a strong
access to work with and the other axis
is this one here so I'm gonna rotate
this now hit our hit option and type in
90 degrees get copy here and so you guys
can see that okay so these are our grid
points here all right so I want you guys
to keep that in mind here I'm gonna make
this a left inner I'm gonna show you
what's gonna happen here
and this week what I want to do is to go
a little bit more in-depth so I'm gonna
go a little slower and try to get the
designs to work versus just plowing
through them okay now I'm gonna lock
these two instead of locking them
actually I'm going to bring them to a
different layer I'm gonna bring them to
my top layer here
I saw bring them to my bottom layer let
me unlock that crank it down there okay
so they're there did I grab both of them
I did not try again okay now I'm gonna
lock that later okay
what we want to do in design is try to
build off the tension that exists
between these two grid lines that I've
drawn for you so the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm gonna use my type
tool here and I'm just going to space
out resonate like if I space this out
over here and then bring it back why
can't I space it out anymore
that's strange I'm trying to to draw my
eye up and down this access point and
I'll show you what I mean in a second
here if I had an element up here so let
me hide this background layer for a
second so if I had another element here
let's take this and bring it up here and
then I have to toggle this line on and
off because because the line becomes
part of the design you'll start to see
that you're gonna get some more dynamic
action going on here pulling the grid
apart and making those things line up
now as I mentioned last week try to
resist using too many tricks because
when Milkha was talking our eye goes to
the greatest point of contrast right so
it's gonna go up here because there's a
lot of white space and really bold type
and then there's some really thin type
next to it that's really nice and then
there's this other thing this features
where you're going from one tint or one
level of transparency and you're making
it less and less now my is like going
down here and really I just want to
focus up here so if we were just to take
this and I drop this okay and probably
not track it out so much let me go into
the type panel here it's so far apart
so this is actually kind of interesting
now this becomes a bigger focal point
for us because the letters are closer
together is more ink on the page that's
blackest as Milko was saying so now we
kind of need to find a place for this
and the the tension and the alignment is
really what makes this layout start to
sing okay so I want to encourage you to
try to just work off those two major
grid points and you can see because it's
off axis like it's hard for me to find
where they line up precisely it's it's
it's quite difficult actually
so this is one of those things where you
need to kind of figure out your design
and then and then move it that way but I
think I had this down here so what I'm
doing is I'm pulling the grid apart and
aligning things not just on this axis
but I'm also rotating the type but it's
still building off that strong grid
point now the last thing I'm gonna do
here there's some funky things going on
and there's a lot of like weird spacing
I think is it or is it my imagination
like this is tighter than this and I I
would discourage you from doing so many
tricks in here so I'm gonna take this
I'm gonna make them all the same let's
see if I was imagining that there we go
there's no point for us to play around
with so much weird letter spacing there
it didn't really make your design any
stronger and there's a good chance that
I might have messed up your design in
copying and pasting in here so I
apologize in advance if that was the
case and I'm gonna keep playing around
with this I like the attention where it
comes it gets cropped off the screen
like that and also offsetting this they
don't have to line up like that
this is 19.2 and lighting this is also
19.2 I could try to bring those two
together a little bit since resonated so
spread out and continue to play around
with that the last thing I'm going to
try here is to take your layout and just
to reduce the point size so if I were to
reduce the point size down to eight
point type look how the feeling of it
totally changes it's much more Airy and
we can work on that there's lots of
things you can do but I'm gonna leave
this one like this okay now this person
Tristan stoner similar kind of ideas and
playing around with stuff but I feel
like Tristan's got a better grasp of
scale and weight and spacing so Tristan
good job and also Tristan's helped me
out a lot because there's no no boxes
for me to accidentally grab and
manipulate as moving things around
Tristan has also done a very good job
with using all uppercase here and then
upper lower here and I think that's
quite nice because it creates a
different level of density and just from
afar you can see how it feels one has
his up-and-down movement and one is more
of like a bar across and Tristan's also
done something quite nice here in terms
of opening up the tracking in this issue
and features and doing this at all
lowercase so Tristan seems to have a
very good sense of hierarchy and how to
control the weight
the
wait on screen when you have very few
parameters to work with just as a
reminder everybody's tuning in or using
one point size in two weights and
there's something that's also kind of
interesting here as as the two weights
Tristan is using light or thin what is
this this is Helvetica light and then
using bold and italic and I like that
choice it's a smart choice because it's
in the same family but the bold italic
is even more different because it's at
an angle so one principal strong grid
not too many tricks involved here pretty
simple straightforward and it looks
really clean and nice that's my two
cents
Milka as I'm talking feel free to say
whatever you want to say and interrupt
me or add something if you want but I
suspect Milko is also busy combing
through the many files to find which
ones that she wants to talk about I'm
gonna quickly shift gears there this is
a yunji Jeong again guys if this is not
your layout I apologize I was cutting
and pasting and putting people's names
in it got a little confusing for me so
if I screw up I apologize in advance
let's do this in the spirit of wanting
to learn from each other okay this is a
very nice clean layout in my opinion and
B all the of the fuss is right here in
this area here the resonate kind of
creating this pattern and making also
the number-8 and also feels like
infinity to me if you follow this and
it's more it's treating the type like
illustration and I think that's that's
pretty cool not the easiest to read no
problem you know why because resonate
it's down here and I actually don't mind
this okay so if if ung were to try to
like do a lot more tricks and repeat
elements like this can somebody hit me
please
or my team can maybe you guys can help
me out there if if you try to do too
much in a layout it starts to compete
and this is like one clear focal point
very simple layout later on I suspect
when we have the option to add different
point sizes if she were to make this
shoot make this bigger he'd be even
cooler
we're looking for that contrast right
but obviously we can't do that for now I
think this is kind of clever most
circular layouts don't work because it
makes it tight very very hard to read
and I'm gonna show you an example right
now let's see if she broke any rules
they're both gray okay looks pretty good
and those of you guys that watch this
replay later I found this a little bit
odd though to be honest here where the
names are really bold and the features
and thin the hierarchy feels a little
funny to me but it's okay may I jump in
on that yes I actually encourage my
students doing bad work
I shouldn't say bad well what do i what
do I mean by like things that are weird
I should say because if you don't do the
weird work then you have no idea what is
a good work does that make sense
absolutely so I wanna actually number
one we don't want to I don't want to
know who did what because I want to cut
the umbilical cord and just talk about
the work itself so so this way nobody
has any hard feeling and this one no
one's gonna say oh they like my work but
they didn't like my work no it's not
about that let's cut the umbilical cord
but what it is is that we want to make
as many mistakes as possible so we can
learn from the mistakes as Chris and I
are talking about it so you can improve
upon that so I'm glad that you did that
so Chris could bring that to your
attention and and talk about that great
and we've encouraged people before to
try to push the edges because we saw a
bunch of layouts where people were
tiptoeing towards the edges just jump
full force and then you can find out
what what doesn't work and then you you
bring it back to what what works okay
and I'm gonna show you the example right
now so here's a circular layout this was
submitted by Loredana Sabha and I do
that just a credit we're gonna forget
who that person is I don't know this
person personally right and so this is
one of those layouts where there's kind
of like this bullseye these circular
lines and yes we can do these kinds of
things and makes the type very difficult
to read look I wanted to get your take
on this particular layout what are your
thoughts on this one did this sort of
desires are very unique and I again am I
command to you for trying it out good
job good job
my issue with these designs is that how
the circle is like the former one we had
two circles and then we had two straight
lines at the top my question was that
are they talking to one another that's
the key element because if they're not
talking to each other then one is
speaking Japanese and one's speaking
Chinese or Arabic or Farsi if that makes
any sense French or German you want to
make sure we're all speaking each
other's language and they're connecting
with one another with this piece that
you're just having in front of you
Loretta
Loredana I hope I said your name
correctly it's it's engaging it's it's
got that kind of a sunburst effect to it
but the question is is that what you
wanted to resonate is this about that
sunburst effect if that's the case then
I think that this work does work does
that make sense yeah some some issues
you're gonna have here is because it's
circular it's very difficult to designer
on this with copy and my eye is looking
like where do I start to read and then I
start to realize a lot of this is
repetition and so I started in the
center dice on the outside because as we
talked about last time little read from
top to bottom left to right where I give
this a pass and I think there's actually
a really good layout in that this is
mostly treated as illustration it's not
meant to be read and so it's totally
okay where is this like I do need to
read this and had to start to figure it
out okay and you don't have a lot of
control there it's very symmetrical
things are flipped and repeated and so
when you actually have to set real body
copy and you have to get people to read
then this is gonna be a struggle for
folks all right and there's a time and
place to do this especially in the
experimental phase we're gonna really
encourage you to try and break
everything and you're gonna see layouts
from some avant-garde designers like
David Carson break all the rules but
he's able to make it work okay now I'm
gonna jump over here just because it's
next to this this is from King win who's
submitted things just before and King I
may or may not have changed your
typeface because sometimes I'm not able
to look at your files okay and here this
just a really simple clean layout in
it's beautiful it's well proportioned
there's dynamic spacing between the
different elements between the journal
for graphic design resin 8 I get that
and then in this issue so you're using
light one of the things that you guys
are getting away with as we're seeing a
lot of people do right now is to use
tints so this is a tint I think oh oh
hold on a second here it's actually not
attempt using different color but what
happens here is in thin typefaces like
this when you go to print this for real
you're gonna see really fine dots in
here and the thinner the typeface you
start to lose the integrity of the
letter form itself if you don't believe
me guys everybody who has a printer
print some of your layouts and look at
them on paper and see what happens with
your transparencies transparencies and
tints work best with thick big bold
things for example if we're in that
phase where we could make this really
really big right like if that were the
layout and you were to go and change the
transparency of this and I'm gonna make
it like 30% transparent these things do
work because it's thick and big enough
bold enough that it should hold up in
print but thin lines very difficult to
work with so check your layout that way
on screen it works fine so I'm giving
you two sets of guidelines one for when
you're designing on screen and for
screen use only and one for a print
application different rules apply okay
and Chris may add to what you just said
about this layout
can you get to see my pointer or not you
don't see my point I can't see your
pointer you don't so what I want to say
is what makes this layout beautiful if
you look at it look at this space not
just the typography so this this work we
have medium background space and then we
have large space thank you very much yes
Chris exactly we're gonna beautiful
thank you
exactly so we have
aha we're perfect and then and then next
below that we have a large space keep
going on
oh you doing double of that oh okay
and then below that you have this small
space so if you go below the text uh-huh
keep talking he'll Alyssa good job
fantastic so that's what's making this
piece work you see that so you have
medium you have small medium and large
and you don't want to have it go in that
order you don't want it to go be small
medium large you do want to play around
with it you don't have it large small
and then medium so I just wanted to add
to that good job thank you for doing
that
so if you keep talking I can I can
illustrate okay oh good teamwork yes
it's a tag-team ok so here's another one
this is from Don Lee here so resonate
resonate ok January February ok so this
is using a bigger typeface
point size and I like that you're you're
trying because a lot of people after
last week went really small and I get
that of course I encourage that but then
I see this so we have some things here
like these lines that you're using to
separate them the they're very effective
at separating and allowing me to read
the different names like Joseph Milla
Brockman between Lester Bo and Luke
Dorris Minh but then also the lines
become a very strong focal point and
sometimes as a separator it should play
second fiddle to the names themselves so
there's something for you to consider
there are other issues here in terms
like the letting being so tight that
these letters jam into each other to the
center of the J bump into the ascender
of the F and so that that is a little
bit problematic you can solve that by
opening it up but it's also ok like I
and here's where we're probably anything
into trouble and I'm gonna do this and
people those eyes are probably gonna
roll if you open up the letting you you
don't have that problem does it
inherently change your layout I don't
think so like making it tighter so
here's where you get caught in no
person's land or no-man's land which is
if you did it like really tight like
this you're like okay I'm really pushing
the boundaries of legibility and
using typist texture and it's very
intentional or you go back out and you
say okay you know what very legible it
breeds everything's cool somewhere in
the middle is kind of where you run into
trouble like did they were they aware of
this thing happening up here if they
weren't and it's something for you to
consider okay and Chris if I may add to
what you just said if we look at the
length of the lines notice that let's
let's talk about paragraph typography
what you want to do is you want to have
your lines if you're gonna have it if
you're gonna have it adjust it align
left and then ragged right you want to
have your lines to be short long short
long so this way that I can follow
through but what's happening here is
that if you if you a Chris would you
mind draw a line wrapping around the
edge of the rags please yes for me
notice that yeah if you notice you can't
keep just dragging just a quick drag
uh-huh
beautiful we're sick are you doing such
a beautiful job that's perfect notice
that what do we have we have a shape and
that's not what we want we don't want to
have a shape because then what happens
that shape speaks louder and starts to
compete itself with the form on the on
the left side and notice wants another
thing that is probably fighting off here
and Chris if you zoom out a little bit
please uh-huh keep keep going about
perfect notice that how if we talk about
the white space here we have equal
amount of white space almost every other
space so the top space from the top of
the top of the page to the word resonate
that's one length that is almost equal
to the length
uh-huh exactly from the space between
resonate and January perfect it's almost
echo and yes and the bottom so be aware
of these things where things are
almost the same amount if you want to
create something that is dynamic you
want to be aware of this and make sure
like the one that we talked about last
one where you have short medium long
space in your composition one more thing
I'd like to add to this piece is that
it's only dealing with a short little
line resonate and then a big gigantic
body of work right the question is
where's the medium
do we need but but then you might say
but milk oh we don't have any space for
medium but then ask yourself this
question can I take anything from
resonate maybe the letter R and push it
somewhere else or take the word 8 and
make it the letter 8 and put it
somewhere else so this way you do have
very small and aha and then it kristef
you can take the letter 8 out please
and then Christi you just tell me where
you want to put that maybe you put it oh
you want this to be ok
uh-huh yes separated uh-huh exactly
perfect
and then yes beautiful and then now you
have three elements to work with and
then the question is where does your eye
go first because right now my eye goes
to resin first and then the body and
then the eighth and then all that space
around it is dead
space so the question is how do you
reorganize these three elements where
your eye travels around the page and
Chris did something beautiful in the
first piece where he had the elements go
off the page
so maybe the body copied January goes a
little bit keep going keep going keep
going
goes ah yes and then the letter 8 goes
off the page to the top a little bit ah
beautiful and let's look at it so now
look how dynamic this layout becomes you
might say but it's not look it's this is
all over but what I want beautiful Chris
but I what I want to show you how the
page becomes even more dynamic now my
eye goes don't boom boom you see that
does that make sense I see it
boom-boom-boom do you remember Rebecca
Mendez Chris you didn't have the hair
did you did you did oh you did not like
it she was very dynamic as well she was
one of my professors yeah okay very good
thank you for helping us out with that
lay out some very good advice and tips
here so we're gonna look up the rag what
we're talking about as a rag remember
look at the rag and I'm not going to
focus personally right now too much on
the rag but I'm really glad that Milka
did because I'm really trying to fix big
architectural problems first you know
but I guess it is important to bring
these things up you got to consider the
rack and how it rolls yeah and you never
want to break them I'm sorry to
interrupt you never never want to break
the name of anybody like I'm noticing
Saul and then the next line says bass
you always want to make sure the full
name is on one line always yeah yes and
then Joseph Mueller yeah yeah yeah
Justin Mueller Brockman is a piece of a
name to work with so rearrange the names
they don't have to be in that order
today and if they say oh if they you
know you might want to negotiate with
the body copywriter could we negotiate
and move the names around so it will
become long short short long yeah nice
yeah so we got to work on that a little
bit okay so some ideas for you guys to
play around with I think it's really
helpful to see that we don't need a lot
of visual tricks or gimmicks to make the
layout interesting by pushing things to
the edges kind of exploring the visual
tension that exists between things and
still creating space for us to look at I
think makes for a really nice layout
okay let's keep going here
next up is Joshua Gilley so Joshua
Gilley very simple layout and I think oh
by my eye I wonder if this has been
accidentally stretched here it has okay
so this is generally something that I
would kind of
upon to encourage you guys to leave the
integrity of the letter form intact I
noticed this typeface looked a little
bit more extended and if you're gonna
stretch in a direction it's preferable
that you stretch wide which is what you
did instead of compressing it vertically
but I think what you're doing is you're
changing the proportion and this may
have been accidental because sometimes
when we move type around and we grab it
by the boxes and we accidentally
stretched a type so let's not do that
okay
so I'm gonna select all of this type I'm
gonna change it back to 100% and you'll
see as soon as I do the proportions of
the typeface look a little different
unfortunately some things are running
into each other now okay we got a little
bit extra information here okay so now
I've turned it back to normal guys you
see that the proportions look a little
different they look more pleasing to my
eye of course if you're an old-school
crazy nut like myself I would say just
probably never stretch type if you can
avoid it and I think you can avoid every
single time okay and I think what Joshua
is doing is he's looking at this like a
canvas and putting dabs of paint and
brush marks and strokes across and he's
using the letting and the spacing of the
letter forms to that effect I think it's
quite it's quite nice we need to kind of
keep working on this a little bit I'm
not quite sure why 2018 is flipped
around I'm not sure that it serves any
purpose at all and I'm gonna flip it
back and we're calling a lot of
attention to this and maybe maybe we
don't need to right now
and especially because I'm reading this
down resonate there's an extra eight
down here which I again I'm not sure so
let's get rid of this one
and we're gonna do this take this one
here whoo this is kind of strange
this is one one one more time where I
just don't think you should put it in
boxes because now I have to constantly
adjust the size of this and it's gone
Chris may I please if you go command-z a
couple of times the place where you went
to go back to where you flipped the 2018
please ah beautiful stop right there
no okay okay let's grab so I let reverse
2018 one more time the way you had it so
flip it flip 2018 please so command
forward give me a second oh sorry about
that I can't come in forward now okay
okay let's grab the 2018 and then this
let's move it to the left a little bit
you will make this right reading reading
the correct way I want to bring it out
you know what because right now what's
happening there's a segregation there's
a segregation of this column of white
space and then this big column of text
ah the question is how can we make this
integrated so if you bring that 2018 and
scoop it out look what happens the 2018
if you just bring it to the left is that
possible yeah uh-huh yes keep going keep
going keep going okay nice well
somewhere run but now a little bit scoot
to the right now good stuff yeah perfect
okay yeah but I just want you guys to
get the idea look what happens here
you're creating this square box where
you having the law of third happening
almost so you've got uh-huh exactly
you've got that vertical line which is
ax doing an access where where the mm
teen is the am i showing that does that
explain correctly yes so you have the
vertical access and then when you bring
the 2018 act out then you're creating
avert a horizontal access and that is
your focal point
and the I likes that
okay so it we need to massage this even
further but I thought by bringing that
2018 out it will help the layout a
little bit more it still needs to be
massaged yeah okay so I want to talk to
you a little bit about how this thing is
set up here this is a confusing text
block to me and it's kind of funky to
work with so I'd like to use to kind of
go in here and just type rez then eight
like that okay and I'm gonna I drop this
so that I can get that point sighs okay
and then I'm gonna go and adjust the
lighting here to like 250 okay that's
probably too much and go to like 50
maybe yeah somewhere between those two
is probably right hundred okay now see
this is really difficult to work with so
and I'm going to also get rid of this
let me try that again
let me delete this okay I'm gonna bring
this guy back and now I'm going to just
using my keyboard was there an extra
letter in here and I get rid of the e by
mistake here looks like it got chopped
yeah I'm gonna bring it back so I'm
gonna bring this back right around here
okay and then now I can hit an extra
return and then work with this eight
pushing pass right pushing past D
yeah I like that right so now what Milko
is saying is like we have a strong grid
line it's strong vertical thing and
she's a boom snap pop crackle she's
doing all the sound effects you can push
it out if you want so you don't have to
line it there so you can see it creates
a different rhythm where I suppose one
line and now let me do it in red
I can do it like this and I'll show you
what happens here and it comes down and
it bumps back out so I'm just trying to
make you aware of the whitespace I
messed up on that line obviously but
whatever okay you guys can see that so
you're creating all this kind of tension
it's wonderful stuff to be able to play
around with this I think like I said
before I don't think there was a reason
why we needed to flip this that way and
again things are in text boxes guys not
for this you see how like I have to grab
extra points and do stuff as I'm
adjusting things and we don't want that
I think it was a great suggestion from
Milka to kind of push this around and
you're gonna have to find out where it
should live now ideally if you if you
move it up to where the Journal of
graphic design is I thought you just did
it align it with the line where it says
the Journal of graphic design and then
move it to the left
uh-huh and squeeze your eyes squint your
eyes what do you think oh no no no it's
too II cool no I don't like it okay you
try you have to ask what if whatever and
a lot of people who look at our layouts
when we're working on this like wow he
made it worse what we're doing is we're
trying and if you're sitting here
designing you're gonna find out like oh
I don't know what else to do with this
type well you have to be able to try
right again you see this is in this box
this is just annoying me to no end here
so I'm gonna just release it from its
box and say you're free my friend go
you're free range typography now now I
can open up the tracking to something
like probably a hundred and fifty maybe
oh that's not enough it's gonna be like
600 maybe that's not enough either okay
I have an extra letter space there so
let's keep going let's go wild like
3,000 yeah there we go know what we what
we don't want to do is sum some of these
I is reading down resonate we don't want
them to get stuck on the number and try
to resin one eight so if we change the
weight there they hopefully will be able
to still read it and push down past that
and anchor down not I'm here okay nice
nice push and pull I think again here
we're using
different tints which I'm gonna just
tell you guys right now let's not do
that anymore for this so I'm gonna I
drop this and just we don't need these
extra tricks they don't really add a
whole lot to it because the contrast it
gets into that no person's place again
no man's land you don't need to do that
I think you can also separate this out a
little bit by adding an extra return
here maybe maybe breaking up this
information and I'm gonna do the same
here right so you're gonna start to see
you know things are starting to open up
now as soon as I did that I created a
new problem and milk is gonna be on me
like in a second she's like what about
this relationship between these elements
and it's totally true once you move one
thing something else is gonna break and
you keep working on it okay
Joshua overall good job I'm gonna hit
save here in case something happens I'm
going to keep going
and just you and everyone else be aware
of the piano effect so when you're doing
dark and light dark and light be aware
of that you want to avoid piano effect
unless your article is about piano and
music right oh I see what you're talking
about you're talking about the keys like
ebony and ivory yes yes all right
don't use a lot of metaphors so be aware
of that are you referring to a pattern
in those colors or like what is that
describing if you look at a key the
keyboard you know it's like a white keys
and Black Keys right I think there's a
term for I don't know what that term is
and when you're doing in in here when
when they were alternating between each
like one being lighter gray one being
darker gray she's seeing that effect
like dark light dark light dark light
do you remember mark correct yep yeah
and thanks for asking that you know what
I want to do I'm gonna take a really
quick pause right now and and look to
the YouTube comments how we doing on
YouTube mark I'm afraid to open it up
because maybe I'll break something if I
do yeah well we got some really good
comments people love you Milka so I
think that's first foremost the energy
you bring but then the the approach in
how you critique is complimentary with
Chris so I think people are loving it
and to watch your back thank you there
was a question by Chris
no I second hi Gracie sorry I was muting
I was like it's always the guest that
gets all the love I'm just chocolate as
soon as I'm bring somebody
no it's been really great to have you
here milk I like the way you talk about
typography and and I do hope that you
will come back oh my and this is such a
good synergy are you kidding me this is
perfect
we've never done this together before I
always knew you and I make a perfect
couple but I Rafi design partners that's
what she yes yes metaphorically speaking
okay so mark if you can seem to continue
to monitor the comments you guys if
you're watching this live on YouTube go
ahead and make it go crazy but telling
us where you guys are from we'll see
this later just drop in your city
everybody's working from home and we're
hoping that you're learning while you're
chillin with us okay let's move on to
Christina tostada and Christina had a
layout that was submitted last week as
well and so I'm seeing some consistency
here I pulled out this layout so first
I'm just gonna take a look at this Chris
can I jump in for a second worse please
Chris
yes I love that resonate at the very top
how it's exactly picking itself out of
the page because it's telling me there's
more and I'm interested to see more and
I call that the satellite because it
takes you out of the page and then where
you have the word resonate it brings you
back in does that make sense that
vertical and horizontal axis they're
working very beautifully together in
that area not only these two things here
yes yes okay now I have a question for
you about the satellite and an earth
station here bringing this back I really
do I'm enjoying this very much I may be
having more fun than anybody that's
doing this right now is that how do you
feel about the repetition and
information this is satellite lose some
of its impact because it's being
repeated you know I'm glad you mentioned
that I when I taught this class I
usually refrain from repetition till
experimental stage because I wanted the
focus to be on the content right now I'm
looking at this in terms of visually
yes sir in terms of form I'm just
critiquing in terms of form but in terms
of repetition you're absolutely right
but it sounds like she's aware of that
and that's what she has subdued it into
a light color otherwise I refrain from
repeating unless there's a reason behind
it okay so I I think I know how to
critique this with you maybe what we do
is we just take turns
so nobody has to feel the pressure to
like figure it all out and I like this
kind of back and forth energy we've got
going on so I like this soon and I'm
gonna be a sucker every time you guys
show me something that creates a little
visual tension that's pushing the
boundaries and breaking the edges I like
that a lot I I'm thinking when I move
this down here I noticed that usually
the stronger alignment for me for me and
and Milka this is where feel free to
disagree or agree to disagree is if I
draw a line here
okay you see this line I think that
strong or lineman is almost always on
the base line beautiful edge in the base
line so that's that would be my one
suggestion there but I have another
suggestion I'm noticing something here
I'm gonna draw a line because we want to
be aware of the negative space that's
being created and you're my eyes going
here so I see it's they're stepping
thing and it's going from left to right
and the rhythm to me to me could be
improved we just took this and aligned
it with that so I'm going to delete this
maybe maybe and maybe it sucks oh one of
these ink these points to see like what
happens maybe it's too even there but I
think if this were treated like this it
would be really beautiful negating the
necessity for this altogether I agree
you made it even more dynamic beautiful
job thank you okay anything else you
want to say about the layout III agree
about the staircase effect it's bugging
me and and when you push the resonate at
the gray resonant at the top I think
that really made a positive impact on it
even if you take it one more step over
let's see can we read the resonate I
think I hunt beautiful that that I can I
can say okay but I'm still not happy
with a staircase of it because I see it
and you don't want your audience to see
a staircase unless that's the article is
about is the article about staircase
then leave it there but if it's not a
staircase then just be aware that that's
where you know your audience
mind Michael and Chris I love how you're
coming in and you're refining things
because I don't have my I don't have
access to it so I can only talk about it
in a fake picture so I'll talk about it
in a big picture and I really appreciate
how you're going in there in details and
refining it and asking better questions
thank you okay I'll be your hands I'm
glad to be your hands usually that
offers nobody but today we're kind of
just looking at tension and rhythm here
some one of the things I noticed here
just from a technical
you're using the text link box and the
overflow feature and it's going from one
thing to the next I think so if I were
to shorten this thing this becomes
really problematic for me because it's
just more things to deal with you would
normally use that for body copy and link
all the text so that if you make a
change in ripples across for layouts
like this it's probably not necessary
and actually will slow you down I also
notice that this is a separate character
from that and in case you didn't know
how to do this
what you do is you just type in the
number eight here this is gonna get a
little techy here for a second there's a
baseline chef right here which you can
say go to 15 points up which is
obviously too much now and three three
and that's really what you wanted to do
so you keep all your elements together
and you don't have to worry about that
being separated okay so that's just a
little technical thing there like I said
before I would really have loved this
beak a copy that isn't repeated but we
get the idea it's a nice idea okay let's
keep moving on all right well if
something happened on this one did
something happen here why is this one I
can't see anything
oh thanks Jonah Jonah's got eagle eyes
or something over here
this is fun farmer Jonah can see through
zoom in the internet he can peer into my
desktop and even see that I messed up
there excellent job Jonah okay so
Jonathan farmer I think I had to
reconstruct his layout a little bit so I
may have moved things around
accidentally but here it is
your thoughts Milka okay good number one
a Jonathan beautiful job in terms of
having the length of short medium long
right so we have the word resonate in
terms of height it's very very short and
then below that I can't read it
whatever it is it's got the medium
height and then to our left we've got
this long length a good element in that
respect the other thing is that we have
we have the shorts with and the medium
and the long width so the short width is
from the long line to the left on the
side mm-hmm yes and then the body copy
on the bottom right is the kind of a
medium length and then you you were
aware of that and you try to stretch out
the word resonate to make it as long as
possible so we can pull that 11 more
make it longer and make the medium one
shorter so we have one two three I like
that um in terms of readability mmm god
it's difficult to have white text on
black background for that reason there's
a lot of tricks that needs to be used
one is you might have to go bolder to
you have to have go bigger three you
have to add extra tracking in there so
the letters can stand that and read
themselves so my kudos to you for being
so brave in terms of going this really
far having a black background because
it's awesome job in doing something that
was very very daring and now we can all
see and go ah I get it what happens if
we do it this way so now I'm gonna throw
it at Chris Chris how would you resolve
the problem ooh
okay so III I also like components of
this and I like that you've I think this
is one of the first layouts where I saw
you breaking you the first and and
second the first and last name apart
which now gives you double the elements
to work with because some of you guys
like what else did I do and I like that
right and what I mean I'm gonna scan
over because I've prepared this
in advance for you guys okay look at
just in the hands of a talented
typographer you can see how information
can be manipulated readjusted and
configured to whatever you want alright
so this is the list made into a
paragraph and lists typically are not
presented this way and it makes it a
little bit harder to read but it creates
a different block and shape of
information and like we showed you guys
before you can adjust this and change
the column width and you could take this
and free it and make it like a list like
this and so this has yet a different
feeling because this is rather
horizontal where this is vertical and
we're gonna have challenges with the
longest name Joseph Milla Brockman and
that's gonna dictate how this feels okay
whereas Milko was talking before about
the rag the rag right here with lists
like this there's nothing you can do
you're not you're not really supposed to
change their name but everywhere else
you want to control this okay as you're
doing that now I I can also make the
list look like she let me get this out
of the way so these these are kind of
like my cupboard where I have all my
ingredients laid out so it's a lot easy
for me to work with so I have a list now
and I've broken the names into first and
last which makes it twice as tall as
this you can see that maybe even taller
and then I could make the list look like
this breaking into column view and this
is when you want to use I'm sorry
nevermind
I think the text may or may not be
linked together but now I have two
columns and it creates a different
feeling and then the last thing I wanted
to show you was the first and last name
broken apart show Nazz three columns
right so they all have different
feelings and different ways of
presenting themselves so I wanted to
take a moment to show you that that
there's a lot of possibilities here so I
really appreciated the fact that
Jonathan broke this apart like this some
things I don't like and I think I've
mentioned this before I actually I know
I did I'm just saying that is is this is
that I generally prefer you not to to do
something that repeats the dimension of
the page and we can change it quite
simply just by reducing the letting so
that it doesn't go all the way and I
think it's a smarter way of using the
entire
Paige versus just grouping it there and
then making it repeat the dimension okay
I think it's more than a McKee few do
that but the biggest problem I have with
this layout is I'm struggling to find
the relationship between these things
like how are these things tied together
how's my eyes supposed to read this play
out I'm not quite sure just yet yeah
yeah yeah there needs to be some depth
into it I would probably recycle this
layout for the following assignments
where you get to use three different
sizes and then you can add different
weight the arcs beautiful Chris oh it's
looking so much better already and one
thing I was gonna say is I don't like
the fact that the text is boom all the
way to the edge only that and that's
something that you know you might want
to be aware of and again I my kudos to
you for trying it out because the
question is if that one is all the way
to the edge do we have anything else to
the edge that speaks and balances of
that no we don't have that really so I
love what Chris is doing it you know
when you move something it impacts the
the feeling and how these things relate
right so I'm just so this is because
they're so different we have to work
really hard to kind of make them feel
like they belong together but I I just
applaud you for trying something and
pushing it to edge and breaking the nail
that you did so we're not saying this is
a resolved layout we're just showing you
the different problems here and we've
got to sit down and really work on this
to get it resolved what I don't want to
do is close off the space I've mentioned
this before I want to feel like I can
travel through this and up the other
side so I have an idea I have a
suggestion here which is to take this
and make it into two columns I think I
can do it here right what do I set
columns I forget
I really like this layout Chris
beautiful I think Jonathan has the
ingredient yes but he just needs to be
moved around and and that's why I
started with saying with a short medium
long but the placement needs to play
itself around and I like what Chris is
doing beautiful how do you change it to
two columns
I'm not I do a lot of programs for some
reason my brain is freezing right now no
codes do you know to do illustrator to
make two columns I know somebody this
straighter yeah some options here no
well you're looking for that I think
there's a question here that you guys
have addressed here but so Jason's
asking is there a point where the aqua
tension is actually almost more
desirable than just spacing everything
to live in its own world and I think you
guys are answering that by saying that
as long as there's some type of
hierarchy that you know things are
supposed to be grouped together then
that tension is okay you guys have any
comments about that
can you repeat the question one more
time I want to deconstruct it sure so is
there a point where aqua attention is
actually almost more desirable than
spacing everything to live in its own
all right wow what a sentence because
what do you mean by awkward that's the
question here's the thing but the way I
like to focus on design is think about a
focal point focal point is somewhere
where you can always start and then go
from there
and what Chris is doing here is actually
is creating a focal point it's got the
vertical axis and the horizontal axis
and that is a beautiful round focal not
round but that area is or is your focal
point where you want your eye to focus
and the other thing is happening here
beautifully is that your eye is going
out of the page and coming back in the
page so when I read resonate it kind of
takes me out of the page and then brings
me act at the very top come back in and
then with the race so there's like this
rhythm happening here and I really enjoy
looking at this page for that reason in
terms of readability Chris you take on
that because I can't read everything
here yeah I can't either and that could
be easily solved as you you mentioned
just by thickening up the weight of this
typeface yeah its Helvetica new ultra
light so if we just wanted thin eight
it's gonna be much more legible so just
just that under what me okay it said
before there's somehow I think something
is messed up here every go it's missing
some type yeah and that was one wise in
terms of for Mars I hope my critique
comes across in terms of form we're
talking about form in general but in
terms of readability and legibility
there's a lot of issues here that I see
and I and I and I'm wondering if because
Chris has access to it he can probably
point at that yeah so what do you want
to point out tell me in terms of
readability and legibility which you are
right now internet things Boulder yeah
just your weight on black because when
you knock it out
this is another like old-school coz milk
and I are pretty old-school when it
comes to print what happens is when you
lay ink down on a page on a super-thin
typeface the ink starts to bleed into
the paper and you start to lose the
integrity of the letter form so just be
mindful of that and I think once we say
this then you got like paying attention
to that right I realize now why Jonathan
put this in a box because he's using the
digestif force justified option here so
if it were justified left it would look
like that and the way that he's getting
it to space out so what would I sue guys
is let me copy this I want to release it
again from this box so I can play around
with the type I see this box is not
killing me make it there there so this
now like I said you guys we don't we
don't need to use all these tricks it
doesn't have to be that fancy to make it
this to work and you've seen us do this
thing before where maybe we start to
space this out I don't know this is
gonna work well we can thread it so if I
did something where this tied together
maybe and it would rob my eye across
here nice through it it needs some work
for sure okay yeah recycle this layout
for future was beautiful job okay let's
keep going here this is from June you
I hope June I spelled your name right
copied and pasted but you know never
know what happens here now I just want
to start off by saying this is actually
quite an interesting way to do type by
spacing out an angle like this but
there's still vertically oriented and it
creates a very interesting feeling for
me it feels like it's gone through a
shredder
you know like documents are shredded the
alignment gets all messed up but they're
still facing vertically they're still
vertically oriented and so I thought
that was just kind of a very unique and
interesting way of handling this now we
have to solve the rest of the problem
though I'm not gonna turn that over to
you my kuda to you for trying that out I
can tell you put a lot of attention into
doing it so good for you for going in
there and doing something that probably
you haven't tried before I really
appreciate that and I
was pushed my students try things that
you haven't done before even though if
it's really really bad because you'll be
surprised sometimes things are so bad
they're so ugly that they're beautiful
and you see that when you go to the
museums right when you see beautiful
when you see paintings and you go why
display D it's so amazing because it's
so ugly that it's beautiful
does that make sense it's a classic
music it's like I don't know why this
classic music is or even operas like why
is so amazing anyway getting to this
point is that what my problem with this
layout is that they're speaking two
different languages and it looks like
you ran out of gas prosity after you did
the resonate area and then for the body
copy you like okay boom I'm gonna put it
in there there's a lot of issues with
this layout that I'm not happy with and
and just it's just it's just not there
yet I would probably spend another good
30 minutes to an hour on it before I
would like to give some critique on it
yeah because sometimes we can appreciate
looking at things like this and say yeah
that's really cool it's really
interesting and call it out for like the
one aspect but then what happens is the
trigger you make something the rest of
this is like how do I make this work now
and it's really tricky and I think I
think you're gonna cap this effect just
to these and not use the M I don't know
what the m1 m2 2018 is is that called
it's not like four month one month two
that's a very creative way of saying
January in February but maybe it's a
little bit too hard to kind of decipher
so what I would do is I would go and get
rid of this I'm not gonna try to fix
this layout right now because it's gonna
be quite difficult right already I'm
gonna take this and I'm just gonna make
I'm gonna just fewer tricks fewer
effects and just go more traditional
with all that stuff so I'm one of those
features and you're probably in this
issue and just go like that okay now
what we can do possibly is take this and
go back in and put the January maybe hit
tab February
hit tab again and 18 I was at 18 or 19
or I don't know what it was
maybe the tabs are too far apart I'm
trying to get these things to relate but
nice trying to tie this with this not
quite yet Naoko but something like that
on the track may make this work right so
it's like needing something across there
nice transition between the two
languages beautiful I like where are you
going with it and that's all I'm going
with it because I also ran out of gas a
lot so we will keep moving all right Wow
12 and you said you had to leave at
12:30 yes all right so let's let's get
through this part and we'll continue on
and if we don't finish we'll do another
live stream you guys it's okay and I
know everybody will be very sad to see
you go but so let's this is Martinez I'm
not even try to say your last name I
feel like your tie or something because
this name is redonkulous with the
syllables in Vietnam we have one
syllable so this is like a stretch here
and for whatever reason I think you only
had access to Roboto so I had to convert
it to America but and hopefully you have
Helvetica somewhere in your library you
don't even need that many weights of it
and so here's your layout
okay so Milkha take it in and let us
know what you think so it looks like I
see talent in your work but then at the
same token I see confusion why because
in the middle I see all these little
interesting things that are happening
and then at the top there's also these
the interesting things that are
happening in terms of treatment and then
at the bottom you have this layouts and
then the three are not talking to each
other but somehow they do want to talk
to each other it's like two people
falling in love with each other but they
don't speak each other's language yeah
it's like how do they communicate
together yeah so Christopher I like to
see more depth here there's no focal
point there's a heart that's one focal
point good job on that but then and then
the feature the word features being in
dark that's another good focal point but
right now these
are not speaking to each other so what I
want to do is Mike only get my hands in
there and move these elements around and
find a focal point maybe in an axis I'm
kind of an access and then work from
there hmm
I could help so if we do kamancheh foul
and change this I think this is one of
the older designs within our group
because there have been hundreds maybe
thousands of students at this point in
the topographer course and I can tell
because they're using the older copy so
perhaps this person just emitting it not
actually having participating in the
latest critique so I'm gonna encourage
you guys if you're gonna do this do it
with us all right
what the heck happened here do with us
and make your adjustments why is this
all weird
ooh so many weird things going on here
so I'm gonna bring this back together so
I just have to do a little cleaning up
here guys pardon our dust while I do
this I'm really enjoying this Chris the
way you're it's a whole different way of
working in Illustrator oh yeah how do
you I do when I work with typography I
do it in InDesign yeah because that's
where typography hey watch this be
careful how you describe it but the
illustrator can do this in Illustrator
too so I'm learning a lot from you yeah
and then I think I want to rotate this
back then command chef owl this you know
and did we ever figure out how to do
this in two paragraphs or two verbs well
you know what you know what the cool
thing is we don't need to because I have
these elements ready to go here I'll
just take copy that so I said we're
social distancing type here so I could
take this now and cut it
come pace yeah let me take it from is it
l cut delete so I'm gonna try to get the
same idea here as what was here before
do two columns here okay I think what
happens here coca is that we all just
use the tools that were most familiar
with and most comfortable with right so
I've used illustrator most of my adult
life here and I don't use InDesign so
much I my kudos to you it's just amazing
how you were able to quickly zoom in and
out and fix things out that's amazing
okay so the problem I had with the
original layout is you did this thing
where you cut the page off and when you
cut the page in half with that type in
it before it makes it now you have half
the real estate to work with instead of
taking this big open spacious floor plan
you've subdivided into a kitchen and
living room we want to be able to
breathe and let our eye move around we
still have problems here we really do
because this is still this grouping here
it's still not feeling like it's
connected enough to this is not strong
enough in alignment for me so what I
want to do is take this and maybe move
it up here and then now bump this down
so it's going to start to tie together a
little bit more I don't think these are
aligned correctly here and so let me
align it to selection let me just fix
this part real quick just to make sure
it's aligned correctly okay and maybe
now we have to deal with space like how
much space here and so a lot of times
you can just move it down take a look at
it just I feel better does it feel worse
and then take it and push it to the top
does that feel better and will it feel
better if I do this Chris I really like
the analogy just you just use the
kitchen versus a living room yeah and if
you look at the architecture of a modern
design you notice that there is no
kitchen and living room there's this
open space where it flows in and out so
think about that when you guys are
designing your layout think about a
modern architecture layout how the space
flows in and out
I think I have to change where is that
how do you change to type 2 all
uppercase lowercase I thought I was here
command T if you command T I'm giving
you InDesign it might be they have a lot
of similarity but I could look here
change case there it is lowercase hmm
why can I change this probably type in
that very case no you know what I have
more power over you than you think
type what the heck maybe don't maybe
have no power here thought illusion oh
you know what I forgot to check
something here which is are these the
same point sighs they're not okay so I
need to make them all the same point
sighs there we go
yeah and this was meant to be bold what
I do like about InDesign is you just hit
command B and it makes it bold right hmm
sadly that is not true I noticed you're
using the eye drop to make the size the
same yes Wow so that's the fastest way I
not idea okay we're gonna move on so
this is Martinez as work and we're gonna
keep moving on here while we have milk
on the line so this is Matt can't
Matt can't and his lat he's taking
everything he's kind of rotated most of
it makes a lot harder to read so I'm
like tilting my neck you're trying to
read it and he's also decreased the
tracking so much so that the letters I
don't know what's going on here and it's
all in uppercase so some ways not only
it's all in uppercase but it also has a
different rotation so
um I like the area where you have risen
resonate if you scrolled in that area
where it says resident I like how you
treated that yeah me too this is my
favorite part
uh-huh yes but then after that I'm so
sorry I would I would like to see you
spend more time making everything speak
to one another and chris has given you a
lot of good tips I would just soak all
those in and ask myself have I tried
every one of them that he has suggested
me to use and then can I go beyond that
and if I want to go beyond that how do I
do that
oh let me look at some examples oh let
me see look at some typography books or
magazine or layouts let me go on
Pinterest and type in good design layout
get yourself inspired as much as you can
and take advantage of this opportunity
where Chris is critiquing your work and
right now I'm seeing something that I
like to point out to you guys is that
the space between January February at
the very top and the whole white space
you see it's a trap space right Chris
yeah the whole space is a trapped space
and you want to avoid that there's a lot
of and that January February 2018 is
also acting like a barrier it's like
boom boom boom you can't go after that
so it's like acting like a prison more
and I just want you to be aware of that
however if you push it and put it out of
the page then aim I start to speak to
you as a satellite possibly but then
it's everything is relative so we have
to work with the others it's beginning
to get chisel a little bit right it
wasn't me chiseled okay I'm also
noticing about things here
I think graphic is missing a letter here
something's going on
okay it's like too many different oh my
gosh okay
now okay you know what we said before is
one trick just one trick and this is the
trick here all right you got this kind
of echoey thing maybe that's enough
maybe we don't need to do more than that
and now I'm going to try and play around
I'm gonna line this with the eight and
folks the reason that Chris is saying
one trick is because you wanna have a
focal point if you have more than one
trick then the eye is good a little a
little everywhere and it doesn't know
where to go we need to invite you back
for Thanksgiving because I was okay I
really enjoyed this part of it this lock
up here this is a cool treatment here
and the rest of it it needs work
and it feels like you came up with a
strong idea and then it's like I don't
know what to do with this I'm just gonna
jam it around the first thing I'm gonna
do is just tell you man just take this
and rotate it back just help me read
this thing okay and then we can go from
there now we also know that because this
is a pretty large point size we just
don't have a lot of real estate to work
with this may be one of those times when
you just make things a lot simpler and
maybe make this into a paragraph let me
try I don't know if it's gonna work I'm
gonna grab this one copy this come back
here zoom in and paste it in here okay I
dropped this sucker okay now I can get
rid of all this I think now I rotate it
again let's let's see what happens again
I don't know it's not everybody I think
that is everybody could we get it to
work mocha I don't know maybe I yeah I
need to get my yet this one is work
that's maybe we can talk about maybe I
usually encourage my students to go back
and based on everything that we have
learned so far what can you apply to
make this layout better so I would like
to put this opportunity in their hand to
see what solutions they come up with in
the next
opportunity the next iteration of this
yeah yeah okay all right there you guys
go
let's let's keep working on that budget
Matt kudos on this off I kind of like
where that's going now I don't want to
see like 35 more layouts with the exact
same treatment I'm just saying I think
this is a successful treatment
it's almost like an official masthead
for this right looks like a logo - yeah
looks like a logo right so that's that's
what I like about it okay let's move on
and let's squeeze in one more before you
have to run this is staff Fuhrman here
and we doing lines yet because I know
you're doing good but this one I would
consider it in that category because of
the reverse that rez yeah yes I agree so
let's see what happened here
yeah so you we're not allowed to use
shapes and and lines just yet so that
would be a violation of the Geneva
Conference or code there so we got to
get this back here but nice try yeah so
we have another problem here it's
missing the T so make sure you guys
check check for that and the problem
with the way that you design this is rez
and what happens is it reads like resin
I don't know it feels funny to me first
yeah yeah like do we have about four
minutes is there anything else that
you'd like me to participate no your
participate nice job
you know I don't know there's probably
ways to work that out but I love it very
simple you put everything in the corner
here and usually I'm kind of yeah I
don't love that but it's just very very
simple what's one thing they could do to
make this a little bit more interesting
ah maybe this piece is just it's just
it's just like blah you know with all
the respect if I get a client who says
hey Milka I have only 30 seconds left it
designed some
I would boom pass this on to them but if
I want to exercise more more design
energy into this yeah like what you're
doing you're creating a hierarchy by
making things bold and this is sounding
nice nice job this assignment is about
using two different weights and last
assignment was about using one weight
but what else did we have to work with
is space and this is exactly what you're
doing right now Chris you're using space
to make this even better and I like that
okay look at this I just want to show
you guys something so it's strong and
it's alignment to that left edge what if
you just took this I move this hand like
it starts to change it what if you took
these two and move them in a little bit
so you and you and you move this and
like how does that change the feeling of
this does it become more interesting
what happens when you take this and you
put it over here or if you float it and
these are the questions that I want you
guys to play around with what happens
when you take resonate and you bring it
up a little bit more to get stronger
does it get worse I don't know
and you guys okay the beauty about that
layout is that it has the ingredients
that the short medium long it has the
ingredients so I agree with Chris go in
there and do like ten different versions
of this layout and you'll be surprised
how much you're going to learn how much
more you'll obtain from learning what
you're doing
Chris I think you're muted there may be
myself nOCA to to be respectful of your
time first of all I just want to
appreciate you and and I'm gonna give
you if nobody else is going to around
applause here so thank you all right so
I don't want to hold you any longer I
know you're not supposed to go anywhere
but you have something else to do I'll
stay till my car comes in so okay you
just been a pleasure if you want me to
come back at any time any time Chris
it's it's been I've waited a long time
with this I don't think we've ever
shared a camera on a live stream before
have we this is the first time for me
also critiquing work online live well
fantastic fantastic so we're gonna keep
going here and in if Milkha disappears
so just drop out that'll be it I just
didn't want it to be abrupt departure
here
no kahoka it's more about you is there a
website or an Instagram or social yeah
please feel free to connect with me on
LinkedIn you can and if you're gonna
connect with me in the text box just
write something like how you know me and
why you want to connect with me and then
I'll be happy to connect with you on
LinkedIn because that's where you can
find more about my background and then I
have also have a link to my website my
website is Milka dot design and I do
have a password for the clients work but
I don't have a password for my work and
my students work so feel free to dig
into those and drop me a note if you
like nOCA MLK a dot design yes I had
more hot design and that's a working
follower and LinkedIn if you want to
make a connection there make sure you
write her a note because otherwise she's
just not gonna accept any random person
okay so Milko pleasure if you have to go
go but otherwise I'm gonna jump right
back into it I read some of the comments
here in the life actually why don't we
just do this because I mean we've been
talking for a long time now I'm noticing
in the chat and that Christina is saying
that this time was a bit harder than the
last round because she's trying out a
Fibonacci grid and if forgetting that
it's too
not two sizes so next week you guys get
two sizes and one weight so it's all
working within constraints and
limitations it's gonna really teach you
how to master typography and like Milko
said the more variables what you've been
praying for is more variables to play
with but once you get them you're gonna
see how much more difficult it becomes
I'm telling you right now Milkha and I
have taught typography for a number of
years we see it happen every single time
master the fundamentals work within the
limitations so I'm just going to open it
up right now
anybody that's on our live critiquing
group right now perhaps you have a
general broad question it's not a
technical question that we can answer
okay anybody and well they're asked or
you have all they're filling in the
question so I did have one that came up
from YouTube so somebody was asking how
do you fix or treat rag so you were
talking about how the rag you know can
change the way that you visually look at
the pattern of words yeah so you want to
do something like my type instructor
Simon Johnson I didn't have Rebekah
Mendez he talked about it being evenly
uneven so it kind of undulates it goes
in and it goes out but isn't create
sharp lines it doesn't create weird
faces or mountaintops or things like
that so three will make a pattern so on
the third one if you're able to to force
a paragraph break then you're able to do
so and in some words you can hyphenate
to kind of control the rag and that's
what you do and since we're only dealing
with one page not a tricky canoe you can
change the width of the column of the
paragraph so making a wider or narrower
and that will resolve a lot of your
problems until you get a more pleasant
looking rag great question let me know
if there's another question for the
people who are here in our zoom call
with us unless you're crashing this and
you're gonna throw out some weird spam I
would say if you want to just talk to me
just digitally raise your hand and
there's just have a conversation I want
to hear your voices actually so Kyle's
raised his hand so go ahead hey Chris
hey man I want to look at that design
that you and Milko were talking about
earlier that shed was beautiful and used
the space the varying like space pretty
well
early in this dream could have been
might have been kind for a yeah that one
with that marking yeah you know so it's
beautiful and the space is proportional
and I don't want to tread on anyone but
it feels uninteresting like when I feel
like we evaluate our own designs and we
go through the process like this third
step is really surprised and like
nothing surprises me about this like so
how do you like balance making it more
visually interesting with also like
welds and yeah so a very good question
Kyle I think this one is a very simple
beautiful layout and it reads really
well flows it's got a good use of space
there probably some tweaks that we could
have made to it kind of strengthen it
I wanted to refrain from that just
because in the endeavour to try to
create really interesting crazy design
we might do things like this we might
come up with all kinds of tricks to make
it interesting if we forget that it's
kind of hard just to make a classic
beautiful simple layout it's actually a
much more difficult than you might think
okay so here's what I'm going to do Kyle
my challenge to you is if you're one who
tends to go far right and go bananas try
to go all the way left but just make it
like boring super legible clean well
proportioned everything is just spaced
out beautifully and see you see what you
learn from that so those of you guys
that are used to being on one side of
the swimming pool let's swim to the
other side and see what the other kids
are like and let's make friends with
them and that's all I can say about that
if you want to make this more
interesting
where I would put my energies right here
in the resonate or possibly the journal
for graphic design it does need a little
flair and that's where I would push but
without chewing up everybody's time and
trying to break a good layout cuz
usually this is what happens all the
time I take a good layout I try some
things and then the internet just just
hammers me on it's like wow it's much
worse I much prefer the original like
yeah I was just trying trying so that's
that's where we're gonna stay away from
this one okay so good question let's go
back and see who's got the next question
who do we have now can you guys
digitally raise your hand
we know I see is it Lars Lars go ahead
I'll meet you go ahead hey hi thanks for
reviewing my work last week I put a
quick question about the circular which
is kind of a follow-up to what you were
just saying before um I tend to go to
[Music]
something that's maybe but you said it's
more to the right and goes too much to a
visually interesting thing but I always
find that I'm struggling with keeping
legible and readable so your advice
would be to make it quote unquote
more boring and try to contain myself
into making too many tricks and stuff
come on right yeah
so here's what I'm gonna here's an
analogy I'm gonna try to chana channel
my inner Milkha here I'm gonna use a
minute let's pretend like you have this
most amazing spice it could be chilies
it could be saffron
it could be truffle oil something and
you're like this is delicious or even
fat like pork fat right and you know I
love and you can you could you imagine
like the proportion of a BLT sandwich a
bacon lettuce tomato sandwich it's a lot
of stuff and a little bit of bacon and
the contrast between the bread the
tankiness of the mayonnaise the
Christmas of the lice berg lettuce and
the tomatoes really complements the
salty fatty part of the bacon what
people are trying to do is like bacon
and they smother it all over the place
and then you eat it you just like whoa
this is gross I feel gross afterwards
okay so a little bit of spice a little
bit of an accent or really rich
ingredient the Flair that the the right
meaning the crazy designed expressive
experimental typography use a little bit
of it because it goes a really long way
that's what I want you to think about
imagine what's going to happen next as
we move forward and we add more things
like lines and
different kinds of point sizes and
weights and shapes and texture what else
do you have left and now what do you do
during that phase you're gonna make it
really tight and boring work within the
constraints make sure it's really
legible that there's good use of space
negative space in particular and then ah
I feel like it's a little bit boring let
me try this one thing and that's what's
gonna do it I see the same thing
happening with logo designers too many
tricks everything that you have in your
arsenal as a designer you just shove
into that logo and this is why the
design doesn't age well you look at it
like right now it's okay and over time I
goof
so master the foundation the principles
the bones of the house are strong the
foundation is really solid a little win
is gonna knock it off and it's not gonna
knock it over
where you go crazy throw a little paint
on it do some interesting tile work
that's really where you want to spend
that energy okay all right thanks Lars I
believe if there's some of your designs
in here somewhere we haven't just gotten
to it yet and we may not be able to
today but okay
so we also have another question okay I
just saw ng and then we're gonna do dart
are gun done yeah something like that
okay youngji go ahead
on me - go ahead hi so for next week
assignment we will use two point sizes
so with that with one wait oh this is
trying to create contrast with two point
sizes so I can go as high I can use one
super big one super small correct yes
and you're gonna find out something will
be too big or not big enough and how do
you make it work so so much harder this
time just after learning because I
learned so much time looking at so many
more things and I also think I
completely followed what you also said
like I think was easier to just start
with a boring book kind of very boring
view and then start moving things about
at what I did is the opposite I started
with what I had so I was trying to grow
from there but it was getting too
complicated so I'm like so it took me so
much to like digest my other things and
then we started so I think I'm just
gonna jump from a clean slate what I
have you see Miss milkis nodding her
head right now yeah yeah i'm i'm ugiy
I'm pathetic with the challenge of going
through because both Chris and I have
done these exercises cuz we know how
difficult it is but the payoff is so
good you after this you're gonna feel
like a powerful person you can whip out
a design just like that oh thank you
yeah I I I literally went out of my room
to like say I can't do it I'm just gonna
not do it this week and then I came back
I don't know I'm gonna do it and I was
like yeah I'm just gonna leave it but I
know it's good because I learned just so
much and I couldn't hear the review so I
don't even know if you reviewed mine I
think I asked my friends on zoom' that
you guys have some I would love to hear
what you guys said thank you I want you
guys beers or something when when I was
much younger and hairier I was doing
this exercise and just like
okay what else can I do so what we don't
want to do is take what we did last week
it was successful and just just do the
same thing again and make one new change
that you're gonna start to see this this
is very interesting you know when you go
to the fairgrounds there's the game and
it's a water gun right and you shoot the
water gun in the mouth of the clown and
whoever gets more water in the mouths of
the clown that balloon inflates bigger
okay so you'll see like some people get
off to a really strong start oh my god
the balloons getting really big and then
they take their eye off of it and the
water goes astray and then some sleeper
person is just going to then go and
finish and win the race this is
something you want to pay attention to
so we want to give ourselves a lot of
permission to screw up to make really
bad horrific layouts and when we do were
like what did I learn from this like how
can I bring this back from the jaws of
defeat and pull it into victory and
that's what we want to be able to do and
back in the day when we would do this
you guys are gonna do 10 15 layouts
every single week and then you have to
go and do an additional five layouts on
the previous week's work to refine those
and to fix whatever it needs fixing so
by the time you're done with this you're
bleeding topography out of Heights if
you can imagine and it's part of that
rigor that demand on you to understand
it that you start to feel confident and
dare I say you start to master the
principles of design okay and right now
what we're teaching you to do is to
learn how to see really more than
anything else look at what's there and
look at how you can manipulate the
information to make it interesting to
make it vibrant but yet to still make
what you feel is important to be legible
okay we're gonna take one more question
way to get back into it and I think I
might do one or two more and then we're
not we're gonna stop the livestream okay
so I think we want to get off right
before one because a lot of people are
attending Ben's webinar as well Oh screw
bad I'm just kidding you're gonna have
to make a choice I'm just kidding
so it's doc how do you see your name
it's Dara Dara
oh yeah it's Sara okay Dara hey so my
question has to do with working on like
an angle or an accent yeah because my
work I usually equate like an angle
being more dynamic so I'm trying to
figure out how to create like
successful layout that is on an angle
because I work very like one box one box
here so I'm like very good but I do my
design so I'm trying to figure out is it
having on an angle does that make it
more dynamic or do I just use switch
things up yeah so this is an interesting
question Dara is that if you feel like
you can't make it dynamic being so great
in a box then you're in a default to
like let me rotate it and the rotation
is just a different way of cropping the
layout right so I want you to feel
confident and to master making an
interesting straight in a box and then
only then start to play with those
angles okay because that cannot it'll
become your crutch mmm in juris crutch
to be leaning on all the time okay I'm
gonna show you if I remember once we
return back to the design part I'll
rotate some things you know like you
know make it better more interesting
okay awesome so Joshua Gilley
go ahead quickly let me unmute you there
you go hey thanks so much Chris and I
just wanted to ask a follow-up question
you guys had mentioned the trapped space
problem yes I believe it was Matt Gantz
design this means we can all see that if
you could relate that to last week when
we were talking about the little person
walked through the gallery like the kind
of blueprint or floor plan approach I
guess the original design I kind of saw
that that satellite being in a point of
interest that the little person would
maybe walk around if that makes sense
and I'm trying to distinguish when it
becomes trapped space okay watch this
and I'm gonna manipulate Matt's layout
again okay and we'll see all right if I
take this and I start to jam it here can
you start to get the sense that it's
being trapped when looking at and I will
highlight in red right now is this space
here
and I'll quickly draw this so you can
see the shape okay these are the things
that start to clog up and our eye has a
hard time traveling around there oh I
see you see and I'm saying that's what
we mean when we say traps space so I
exaggerated dramatically so you can see
what's happening so when you start to
see your layout undo all this when you
start to see your layout do that and
trapping the whitespace you'll start to
like realize that this is why this
layout is starting to work and some of
these other ones are working pretty good
like there's a lot of room for me to
move around travel and it doesn't feel
like anything's getting cut off and it
feels very dynamic like even this quote
unquote and I'm not saying this boring
layout I'm gonna use it in your language
here that there's a lot of room for us
to move around nothing feels like it's
just being jammed into place now here's
one with dongs work is that it is trap
space here but it's intentional and it's
creating a visual tension that I
actually appreciate a lot once you start
to understand how to work with type
you're gonna start to see like wow
everything they told us not to do I can
do and make work that's the beauty of
all of this okay
like look at this layout Joshua gillies
work here a lot of open space it feels
very dynamic and it's straight too now
if we take something that is saying a
little bit more on the say boring side
and - Dara's comment if I were to rotate
this oh there's something here that's
missing let me bring that back out in a
while what happened there
opacity 100% why is it gray there weight
transfer mode here okay I'm gonna I drop
this something's funny about that there
we go
wrong sides - okay I'm gonna take this
I'm gonna rotate it okay and does it
inherently make it more or less
interesting what do you guys think
things more interesting okay and just
because we cropped it right so this is
the power of cropping so we could take a
boring photo or a layup that's not as
interesting and we can make it more
interesting by just cropping it
differently
and later on when we get to the more
experimental phases I'm gonna show you
some tricks on how to make it even more
interesting than this okay especially
when we get into shapes so that's just
something for you guys to think about
and and to look at but the bones of this
thing the relationship between these
things really doesn't change all we did
was just crop it differently that's all
we did now I'm gonna do one more thing
here I'm gonna take this I'm gonna
rotate it right and then I'm gonna scale
it up to see like what happens to our
layout
so this is what a lot of artists do and
photographers to do they take the
picture and then they find a way to
present that same two-dimensional image
and then using cropping by virtue of
cropping it they can make it bigger or
smaller and change how we feel about it
okay so did that I don't know what the
question was I'm sorry for not that
absolutely answered the question thank
you I get the trap space now okay
excellent
okay so you guys want to go for this
until about twelve fifty five and then
where to bounce because you know Ben's
got an important webinar so let's get
back into it share the screen and try to
bear with just me now I mean I know it's
there's a gaping hole I'm gonna try and
fill okay
so this is from Dewey Dewey okay take a
look at this here okay III think we're
starting to see some examples of this on
what I wanted to highlight for you is
that you can use a bowl this is just
italic what we should done is go bold
italic okay so this is italic and this
is an ultra-light
between these two you guys are going to
start to Sue's to see this that ultra
light can be at small point sizes very
difficult to read as I keep zooming out
you're gonna see the integrity of the
letter forms start to get messed up
there right so just be mindful of that
but I like that there's this really
ultra light next to the italic right so
I wonder is there an ultra-light italic
yes there is and if we started to play
with that maybe maybe there's some
interesting relationship between those
two but I just thought that it was a
nice contrast between these two what we
have right now is we have things that
aren't feeling they're related to each
other
Milkha's example is they're speaking
different languages I just feel like
there are the family members who don't
talk to each other it's all it's like ah
I know we're related but you're a
distant cousin and what we need to do is
try to figure out what how they're
related the other problem is we have too
many elements on a page we have this
this and there's too many groupings so
when you're struggling with your layout
try to get three groups at first and
once you feel like you've got a good
handle on that start to push things
and then you'll start to feel like oh I
still can make you feel related but I'm
adding some visual interest there all
right this is from Dewey and so many
laps to go alright so this is from
dhiraj III hope I said your name
correctly this is another really simple
really simple layout where you have a
vertical column of text and then you
have kind of more of two paragraphs two
very small paragraphs in a lot of blanks
black space and not a lot of tricks here
and I really appreciate this layout it's
clean it's simple it's modern and it's
not trying to be too much and I think
it's quite successful for me maybe one
of those things is you play around with
spacing here because there's such a
strong element here you can see that
it's high so it doesn't really matter so
we just keep pushing things right
in later on I want to show you guys
something here maybe not right now but
later on you could start to play with
things like this where the column begins
at the bottom and it wraps to the top so
it's starting to treat this
two-dimensional plane as
three-dimensional like it's a giant
circle and it can go all the way around
it can wrap around edges so some things
for you to think about as you're getting
stuck with trying to figure out how to
make these layouts more interesting
okay this is from Patrick let's look at
this okay I think Patrick here what you
could do is you could try to make these
things more related to each other
individually you have like strong little
components a couple of things that I
would do here right off the bat again
you guys next week I hope I don't see
you guys putting text in boxes when it's
not necessary the only one that should
be in a box is this one not even this
one you can see like look how hard this
is - oh my gosh this is why I wanted to
pull this one out Patrick look at this
you're killing me on this
so Patrick's spaced out each letter in a
separate box versus just putting on one
line and then either hitting tab and
setting the margins or the tab spaces
correctly look how hard this is just a
design it's so like just to get in here
okay so this is one where your own wood
system and process is fighting you in
terms of your ability to iterate and
think quickly I would try to get the two
base lines to line up it's stronger to
have the base line this is what we would
call also a widow here or an orphan
depending on if you were from America
from Europe different terms the journal
for graphic and the designers left here
by itself so I would just hit return
here and bring those two together now if
you feel like this is the unbalanced
thing and you want to make this feel
like balanced that what I would just
simply do is just hit return here and so
now they're balanced again if you feel
like that's necessary okay there's a
couple other things here I want to show
you something if I type in January
hopefully I spelled that correctly and
then February you'll see something weird
happen here where this block
feels too wide for this right so the
decision to turn it to January February
Jan Feb made it feel more balanced but
let's just say you couldn't do that this
is where you've seen me do this on my
Instagram post which is I thought I just
type out that right I put one space here
okay so it starts to feel more balanced
again again this is a decision a choice
that you have to work with the elements
you were given so that you can create
the kind of harmony you want and given
that this tile then you're trying to
pursue now I have some problems here too
it's like there's a grid point here they
are important the boxers are killing me
to pay attention to this now why isn't
this line up with this I do not know so
I'm gonna just bring it there I'm gonna
pretend that it's perfectly aligned and
then this is relating to nothing and I
want it to relate to something and I'll
show you how to do that all you have to
do is take this / this little thing
which again is in a necessary text box
and bring it over here and get that to
line okay and now I'm gonna delete this
and your eyes gonna be able to take that
and connect it to this now everything
feels a little even here so what we try
to do is bring it up a little closer
maybe that isn't feel so good I don't
know maybe needs more weight so I'm
gonna do bold this is actually extra
information because it's already
contained up here so I'm not sure that
we need this and I bet you something if
you were to delete this it would look
better too so it's just a little dot to
draw your eye down and even if you just
did say 0 1
just to pull your eye down here to make
it connect okay and then we've we
haven't oh here's Kyle's work okay
because I'm Kyle asks a question Kyle I
thought this is really interesting
you're the first person to do this and I
didn't even think of this myself so when
I gave you some kudos for doing this
it's a number this it makes it really
easy to read and you're adding an
additional element this is exactly what
I was talking about trying to encourage
you guys to manipulate the information
so it works for you I have a couple of
problems with that one is it's a little
too far away because I mentioned to you
and they're consistent they're not
consistently space right I think I'll
tell you what's happening here proximity
is relationship so if it's closest is we
belong together it's far far apart and
it's not I wonder if there's the right
typeface is it why does this feel like
not Helvetica so vertical now I have a
Vatican now I wonder what's going on
weird
that's America now
we're did you see that cuz the a did not
even look right see this a I could tell
ok well let's put that aside okay I
don't know why maybe sometimes I want to
copy a knee or something funny happen
there but I really do like that I just
here's another thing that you want to do
numerals are designed to kind of fit
within a certain amount of space so if
you did dang okay
again these boxes are killing me so I
would do 0 1 0 2 that way when you get
to double digits it looks nice and
grouped organized it doesn't feel like
it's very skinny and then it gets really
wide I would just do that ok I like that
part
now Kyle came up with a like an
interesting take on that but then he
repeats the numbers everywhere there's
numbers everywhere to much I like it up
here I like it down here I like it here
but I don't like three times that amount
plus then you have this illustration
that you've done with zeros on one and
putting in resonate okay I think if this
issue were about digital privacy or
something about bits and bytes
I think this illustration would make a
lot of sense like right now yeah okay so
this hat would have to be tailored to
the content I mostly wanted to point
this out that I do like you adding
numbers and playing around with that as
an additional design elements so some
things for you guys to think about for
next week all right now just so you guys
know I'm gonna close this file I think I
I discuss everything on this one we do
have a lot more people to look at and to
look at the work here but we're gonna
have to take pause right now because I
think we're hungry you're hungry and
some of you guys want to attend then
Burns's webinar and it's very important
that we do that so I'm gonna stop the
share get back into it and I'm going to
say goodbye to everybody but I think
mark you might you might have an
announcement or something all right
yes so yeah we just wanted to give an
announcement we have a podcast if you
have not seen our podcast before so we
have a message from our good old friend
Greg so Chris if you want to sign off
we'll end with that I'll sign off right
now guys thank you very much guys I hope
you learned a lot from this session
together I tried my best just to go deep
and be in the pocket versus just
covering as many people as I could
I think Milka added a lot of
dimensionality to this conversation in
the future I will hopefully have her
back as others because you're gonna see
this stuff isn't just pure science
there's a little art and magic to it too
and hopefully having different opinions
and and if we can play nice together you
guys will learn more from that and I
apologize in advance that all the people
who tuned in to have their individual
work critique mark and I will figure
something else out maybe we'll do a
second stream on this and we'll figure
it out so on behalf of the entire team
on mark Jonah and myself guys see you
next time and we'll see you next Tuesday
for typography Tuesdays and mark go
ahead and roll that promo hi my name is
Greg Gunn and I'm the producer of the
future podcast and yes we do have a
podcast in fact we've been having one
for years and that's exactly why I'm
here talking with you you see it's
really good and I think you should
listen to it if you like what we do here
on YouTube then you're gonna love what
we do in the podcast you'll get to hear
intimate conversations and personal
stories from some familiar faces and
others you might not know about yet plus
you can listen to it while doing
something else and miss a thing so if
any of that sounds interesting to you go
visit the future comm slash podcast or
find it on your favorite podcast
listening app I hope to see you there
[Music]